andrew uh i gotta ask you first of all
you're out in alberta filming this was
that a good place to be when you needed
to sort of maybe take a break from the
heavy subject matter of this particular
series dude i loved it i really
genuinely loved calgary and i loved
alberta i loved the people i loved the
restaurants i loved the food i loved the
nature as you say lake louise and banff
and i i just had a a great time i i took
a crazy cold dip in lake louise when no
one else was doing i was like why is no
one doing this and then i jumped in i
was like oh now i understand why no one
is doing this it's very very cold but um
i had and we we would we we were pretty
tight cast and crew up there so we would
go on hikes on the weekends
and we would have game nights it was
really really fun and i must say my
favorite place in all of calgary is
called the repsol center it's a big
sports center and it had a great it's a
shout out to the repsol center because
like it has a great steam room and a
really great like cold plunge and
jacuzzi and big like olympic-sized
swimming pools and workout gear
basketball courts so they i just loved
it that was where i spent most of my my
down time in the repsol center so big
ups to the repsol center
i'm just picturing the people in lake
louise like the regulars there
watching you about to take that dip
going for this guy look at this guy
we'll wait wait what happens this rookie
yeah
um
so this has been in
talks about being made since like 2011.
when were you when did you become aware
of this and what made you want to hop on
board well i so i read the book when it
first came out over 10 years ago that
the krakow book and
i fell in love with it in a way that was
i found it so compelling and so
horrifying and
fascinating you know
and then
obviously you know i i like everyone
else i was like well how are they going
to turn this into a show and a film or
something like that
and then when dustin lance black and ron
howard and brian grazer came and said
well we have a script actually in fx so
doing it it was like oh well that's very
interesting immediately because dustin
is
obviously an ex-mormon himself and has
deep connection to this material
um
it was like well
and then i read it
and he had invented this this character
that i played it's it's a fictionalized
detective jeb pyre that is on this case
and i thought oh they've cracked it
they've really figured out how to tell
the story in a compelling
you know
non-educational kind of true crime way
and uh and i just loved it and i thought
the dilemma that they
gave jeb jeb my character was so
um
visceral and uh kind of
juicy for an actor you know how do you
balance and how do you live in the
tension of the pursuit of truth
that might cost you
you know connection to your family
connection to your community connection
to your church the thing that you hold
most dear the thing that you love that
you've depended on
as he unpicks his own faith
um
just because of the nature of his job
and of the nature of having to honor
you know his duty to honor and and and
protect and the memory of um brenda
wright lafferty and her and her daughter
erica
who are murdered so brutally and
heinously by these two men
well andrew i i gotta commend you it's
the stellar uh stellar show stellar
performance and really gut wrenching to
see which is you know um kudos to you
and the crew and everyone involved all
the best thank you appreciate it thank
you